you
we're here to talk about a biological
machine that you might know as the goat
after they call you the goat whisperer
yeah was stead of the lawnmower helping
the environment i use animals whose
goats what's behind us and what's this
land like what are we where are we
actually in a landfill of hunters point
shipyard oil up to port of san francisco
and they can't use lawnmowers and stuff
back here because it's his land field I
guess supported hired a guy to to graze
the land here and the goats had got out
and I mean 500 goats route you know I
heard of him back in and boss was so
amazed at what I done he said I made it
seem like you have a touch for them one
of the things that you're worried about
happening to your goats where a main
thing is like dog attacks you know it
was like Oreo is very attached to dog
sometime are you think she's a dog okay
you know sometimes it could be dangerous
for you know I quite a lot of kids you
know trying to do things like still the
baby goats but of most of anything is uh
it's the dogs so like how many how many
acres can they do I didn't do we're out
here in the right here where we're at in
100 club of witnesses like nine acres
and they can do this and probably a
month what's the process so I call you
up and I'm like hello David go whisper i
need a goat and then you're just it just
shows up at my house or I come pick it
up down here and putting in a minivan
and is like what happened well what
happens I would come out to the way
where you want to go Stu be I would
check to check the grounds make sure
there's nothing dangerous for the goats
I'll fist a place put up electric fence
portable electric fence when it goes can
stay in that people can stay out you
know let them do the job next week for
example you're doing a job up in the
presidio why wouldn't those people just
you know get a lawn mower get a
landscaping service well it's because of
its poison oak yeah they go in and mow
it is one of their favorites no but I
bringing them home anything so how many
mne go to you bring it out to the
actually going to bring Tin out in the
morning and come back and bring bring
them back in and bring them out every
morning for about a week it's safe and
they get the job done and then they
teach people that animals
from the country can live in the sea the
moat is so it's very awarded like fuzz
the kids like went up to the school the
kids had never seen goats and yes the
ones from the rougher areas of town yeah
so I get like a real feedback from it
that's real positive